foreign
subject of moral relativism
how should we how do you think about
that
this is a great topic to tackle in a
longer discussion because it's
you know it's one of the oldest
questions in philosophy it's an
important one and it takes a little
doing
so there are a lot of intellectual
puzzles where we just sort of naturally
think about it on like a single
Dimension or as a binary and if you kind
of break it up into multiple dimensions
then you see you see Solutions so the
typical way of thinking about this is
there is morality real like is it a real
thing like you know like the laws of
physics
such that if people are behaving
contrary to it they're wrong even if
they don't know it or is morality just
you know and Herodotus in ancient Greeks
they saw this like well in this country
you know they kill their parents when
they get old and in this country they
eat pigs and they they could see that
practice is different and so well maybe
you know it's just like language it's
just like whatever you know whatever hap
whatever happens in your culture well
that's what's grammatical
but what I learned in part from schwader
and also in reading a lot of philosophy
some of which he guided me to was I'll
put out a couple of Concepts so the
first is moral monism versus moral
pluralism so it's the question isn't is
there moral truth or not it's is there
one moral truth or multiple and once you
do that now you've loosened things up
because a Hallmark of my work and this
is where I departed from Rick a bit is
I've always been very influenced by
evolutionary psychology as well as
anthropology so we are evolved creatures
we are Homo sapiens and we are all Homo
sapiens and we are primates and we are
have a lot in common with chimpanzees
and bonobos so that's the evolutionary
site
and then there's also the anthropology
we vary and so when you look around the
world you don't find infinite variation
you find a few major patterns a
wonderful book dancing in the streets
history of collective Joy by Barbara
aaronreich she says when the European
explorers went out in the you know 16th
17th century they found wherever they
went people danced around campfires had
rituals that bonded the group together
they often used psychedelic substances
they had beat Heavy Music so this is
human nature but feudal systems are also
pretty common there are a few major
patterns and so one possibility is
there's not just one way of doing things
but it's not anything goes it's that
there are several different sort of
grammatical human forms and this
actually became the basis of my major my
major work in Psychology which is moral
foundations Theory which is my effort to
say
what are the taste buds of the moral
sense because Cuisine varies around the
world you wouldn't say that the French
are wrong if they don't cook like the
Vietnamese but I think you could say
that the French and the Vietnamese are
both much better Cooks than the English
or at least you know they were
historical
it's not that anything goes there is
some truth
but here's where bringing the second
kind of abstract but really powerful
concept which is anthropocentric truth
so that means something can be true
relative to anthro to humans to who we
are so if if intelligent aliens come to
our solar system they will find that the
Earth is the third planet from the Sun
and that was true before we existed
it'll be true long after we're gone and
they would find that gold is a better
conductor of electricity than is
aluminum that was true before we were
here it'll be true you know so those are
non-anthropocentric truths there's a
fact and so many people have been on a
quest to find what are the moral truths
like and so Sam Harris who for a brief
time was my intellectual enemy we kind
of had like a feud for a few years now
we're friends we actually like each
other quite a lot but we had kind of a
feud over this because he has a whole
book of the landscape of morality
arguing that moral truths are like the
truths of chemistry and I say no
they are anthropocentric traces from a
philosopher David Wiggins
there are things that are true because
of the creatures we are so there are
things that are beautiful
because of our senses there are things
that Shakespeare is a better writer than
Kurt Vonnegut now I love reading Kurt
Vonnegut I probably enjoy it more than
Shakespeare but man I can see and almost
everyone can Shakespeare is a complete
genius at crafting words that's a fact
if aliens come here from another planet
they're not going to agree because it
doesn't make sense it wouldn't fit with
their nature anyway so putting this all
together I think what we can say is
there are moral truths and moral orders
that are emergent I am not a relativist
I am not a monist I'm a moral pluralist
there are multiple moral truths and
these truths are emergent from Human
Nature interacting as people interact in
societies okay wow I think I just did it
oh it's great